GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY
APOLOGIES FOR RUNNING LATE I
HATE BEING LATE SO JUST VERY
APOLOGETIC THAT WALK I'M GETTING
REALLY GOOD AT THE WALK FROM
OVER THE NEW SWING SPACE RIGHT.
SOMEONE IN A WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
ATTENDING THIS HEARING IN PERSON
IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A MASK AT
ALL TIMES- WHILE IN THE BUILDING
THAT. THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS ME.
WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY. OF FOR
THE PEOPLE HERE IN THE OHIO
OFFICE WHO'S IN THE ROOM IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
THE BILL PLEASE LISTEN FOR MY
PROMPT TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT- WE ARE USING THE MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
THE PUBLIC CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THE NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO WHEN THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON BEGINS THE BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THIS PHONE SERVICE
PLEASE CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
THREE NINE FIVE EIGHT MY STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO HELP YOU. WE
ALSO ACCEPT WRITTEN TEST
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
CONTINUE USING MATHIS TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL. OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE STILL FACE. SO
ANNOUNCES COVER COUPLE THE
GROUND RULES FOR APPROPRIATE
CONDUCT. OF THE SAME WITH ME IN
THE BEST BEHAVIOR TODAY BUT
NEVERTHELESS. THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCE IN A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE IMPLORE
PROCEEDINGS OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTRICT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. SUCH IN A CONTACT
MAY INCLUDE TALKING REGULAR
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING ALLOWED THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING LONGER
THAN TIME ALLOWED ALLOWED-
EXTENDED DISCUSSION MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING OR THE BILL. AND ANY
OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS. TO
ADDRESS THAT DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT
I WILL TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS.
IF AN INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS ARE
HEARING PROCESS- DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WANT THEM TO CONTINUE
DISRUPTIONS VERY RESULT REMOVAL
FROM THE CAPITOL BUILDING. WILL
ALSO DOCUMENT ON I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE OF THE DESTRUCTIVE
CONDUCT. I MADE TEMPORALLY
REDUCED RECESSED THE HEARING.
AND IF THE CONDUCT DOES NOT STOP
I REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SERGEANTS AND ESCORTING
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO LET'S GET ON WITH
HIS. WE HAVE SIX ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY TO THOSE ITEMS ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ITEM FIVE.
A. B. TWO THREE TWO FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN. ITEM SIX
S. B. TWO ZERO SEVEN BY SENATOR
DOLLINGER. WE'LL HEAR OTHER
BILLS- ALL OTHER BILLS IN THE
ORDER SHOWN ON THE AGENDA UNLESS
OTHERWISE NOTED. WE WILL TAKE UP
TO TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THESE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY. ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL. OKAY
SO WE HAVE A QUORUM NO WE DON'T
HAVE A CHORUS WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- OUR FIRST ITEM ON
TODAY'S AGENDA IS AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON- PLEASE- PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
SHOULD THANK YOU AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO USE THREE
ALTERNATIVE PROJECT DELIVERY
METHODS AS CLIMATE CHANGE
INTENSIFIES DROUGHT CONDITIONS
IN OUR STATE THIS LEGISLATION
WILL EXPEDIA THE CONSTRUCTION OF
A REGIONAL RECYCLED WATER
PROJECT AND A SET OF DROUGHT
RESPONSIVE PROJECTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE AND I WOULD BE
TAKING ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE IS JOHN BURNER SKI ON
BEHALF OF METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOHN BEDNAR
SKI AND I'M THE MANAGER FOR
ENGINEERING SERVICES AT THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
THE SPONSORS. OF AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE. METROPOLITAN IS A
REGIONAL WHOLESALER THAT
DELIVERS WATER TO TWENTY SIX
MEMBER AGENCIES SERVING ABOUT
NINETEEN MILLION PEOPLE AND
LOCAL BUSINESSES IN LOS ANGELES.
ORANGE RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARD
DINO SAN DIEGO AND VENTURA
COUNTIES. CALIFORNIA IS IN A- IN
YEAR THREE OF A WORSENING
DROUGHT SHRINKING ALLOCATIONS
THE FIRST EVER WATER SHORTAGE
DECLARED ON THE COLORADO RIVER.
LAID BARE THE LONG TERM RISKS OF
DROUGHT ON SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
WATER SUPPLY. IN RESPONSE
METROPOLITAN IS WORKING TO
EXPEDITE. THE NEW DROUGHT PROOF
WATER SUPPLY SUPPLY OF WATER. IN
A SET OF EMERGENCY MITIGATION
MEASURES TO MAKE OUR REGIONAL
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM MORE
RESILIENT. AND ABLE TO ADAPT TO
THE REALITIES OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
AS A PUBLIC AGENCY WE ARE
CURRENTLY LIMITED TO THE
TRADITIONAL DESIGN BID BUILD
MODEL FOR THE DELIVERY OF PUBLIC
WORKS CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
WHICH CAN BE INEFFICIENT. AND
INFLEXIBLE FOR LARGE TIME
SENSITIVE AND COMPLEX PROJECTS
LIKE THE ONES THAT WE HAVE
PLANNED. METROPOLITANA SEEKING
AUTHORIZATION FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL PROJECT DELIVERY
MODELS TO ENHANCE OUR ABILITY TO
DELIVER KEY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. IN AN EFFICIENT AND
TIMELY MANNER. THE ENHANCE
DELIVERY OF PROJECTS AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR EXISTING
FACILITIES IS CRITICAL TO OUR
REGION. AND MANY WATER AGENCIES
AND BUSINESSES THAT DEPEND UPON
METROPOLITAN TO DELIVER HIGH
QUALITY RELIABLE SUPPLY.
COLLABORATIVE CONTRACTING
METHODS LIKE DESIGN BUILD
PROGRESSIVE DESIGN BUILD AND
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER GENERAL
CONTRACTOR ON LARGE SCALE
PROJECTS LIKE OURS WOULD ALLOW
PROJECT. WOULD ALLOW PROJECTS TO
AVOID DELAYS THE CAN OFTEN
HAPPEN WITH LINEAR PROJECT
DELIVERY APPROACHES LIKE DESIGN
BID BUILD BY OVERLAPPING A
PROJECTS DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
PHASES AND CAN ALSO REDUCE RISKS
OF OVERALL COST TO RATE PAYERS.
THE PROJECTS THAT WOULD BENEFIT
FROM ALTERNATIVE DELIVERY
METHODS INCLUDE THE REGIONAL
RECYCLED WATER PROGRAM WHICH IS
A PARTNERSHIP WITH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICTS TO
CREATE A NEW LOCAL WATER SUPPLY
ENOUGH TO SERVE MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION OF SIXTY MILES
THE NEW CONVEYANCE PIPELINES AND
PUMP STATIONS AND PORTIONS OF
THE ADVANCED WATER TREATMENT
FACILITIES WOULD BENEFIT FROM
ALTERNATIVE DELIVERY METHODS.
METROPOLITAN ALSO PLANS TO
UNDERTAKE SEVERAL PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS TO MITIGATE CURRENT AND
FUTURE DROUGHT IMPACTS TO PART
OF OUR SERVICE AREA HOPE THAT
ARE WHOLLY DEPENDENT ON STATE
WATER PROJECT IMPORTS. THE
PROJECT INVOLVED NEW PUMP
STATIONS AND UPGRADES TO LOCAL
CONVEYANCE FACILITIES TO
FACILITATE THE MOVEMENT OF WATER
STORED IN OUR SYSTEM.
COLLECTIVELY THESE PROJECTS
REPRESENT THE RAPID ADAPTATION
TO CLIMATE CHANGE THE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS AND THESE PROJECTS WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM MORE
EFFICIENT DELIVERY METHODS TO
EXPEDITE CONSTRUCTION. IN
CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND FOR INTRODUCING
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE. ALSO WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL. ON BEHALF OF
METROPOLITAN ARE TWENTY SIX
MEMBER AGENCIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE WE GO
ANY FURTHER- WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND THE LIKE TO TAKE ROLE SO WE
CAN CONTINUE. SECTOR AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY HERE. AGUIAR-CURRY
PRESIDENT. ROCKY ROCKY PRESENT
BLOOM HERE. WILL PRESENT.
BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS
THREE OF US HERE THREE OF US
PRESENT. ROBERT RIVAS WILL TELL.
YOU VOEPEL PRESENT. THANK YOU
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. NO ONE KNOWS THE- IN
JULY TO BE IN SUPPORT. OKAY I
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN US AT THE
MICROPHONE YEAH THAT'S PERFECT.
BETTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONACAN ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE ARE IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE A VERY GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE- MET THROUGH OUR-
BUSINESS MANAGE BILLING CASE
MANAGER CHRIS HANDED DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES AND WE ASSUME WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE WITH THAT FINE
RELATIONSHIP. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO OPERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER PEOPLE THAT
MIGHT BE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
ON THE LINE. OR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THAT
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE A
COMMENT FROM LINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS THE BEST A LOT
SO ON BEHALF OF CUCAMONGA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY AND WATER BE IF
CALIFORNIA ALL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWENTY TWO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BIRDS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS KEREN APRIL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HEY WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH THEIR LINEUP. IN LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
BRIDGET MY GALLON FROM ADULTS IN
GOVERNMENT. AFTER THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE
ANY- NO FURTHER COMMENT GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR DO
YOU HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL THAT'S HERE IN THE ROOM
. SEEING NONE OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE THIS IS
OPPOSED TO AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE. COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION. A.
B. EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO THE EURO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT THAT THE-
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OTHER
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
. SEE NO QUESTIONS- ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. OKAY MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUCKY SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
LIKE TO THANK. YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL WE APPRECIATE
THE PARTNERSHIP AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WAS ENOUGH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU KNOW WE NEED
MORE FLEXIBILITY RIGHT SO I'D
LIKE TO THINK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF- AND
TO REFINE THE SCOPE OF YOUR
BILL. DROUGHT AND CLIMATE
CHANGES ARE AFFECTING US IN- SO
MANY WAYS AND I SUPPORT
FLEXIBILITY TO HELP LOCAL
AGENCIES ADDRESS THESE IMPACTS
WITH THE COMING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS I AM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED TO
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I HI LACKEY I LOVE THE
FIVE BLOOMS. WILL FIVE BURGER
FOR. RAMOS THREE OF US HI
THREE OF US HI ROBERT RIVAS HI
ROBERT RIVAS I K. RIGHT. NOW ON
. THE SIXTEENTH THE SIX ZERO AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL PAVE
THE ROLE FOR. MISS THANK YOU
EMILY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT- WELL TO A SOME
MEMBER DALY THIS IS AB. NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. FIVE YEARS AGO SENATOR
DODD TO CARRIED A BILL
AUTHORIZING COUNTIES TO USE THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK
METHOD FOR PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
IT HAD A FIVE YEAR SUNSET THIS
BILL DILUTES THE SUNSET- THE
COUNTIES A SEEM TO BE USING THE
METHOD AND ENJOYING IT. THE
BENEFITS INCLUDE FASTER AND MORE
EFFICIENT PROJECT DELIVERY
IMPROVE COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE PROJECTS OWNERS THE DESIGN
FIRM AND CONSTRUCTION MANAGER.
AS WELL AS GREATER TRANSPARENCY
REGARDING FEES. HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF KIANA VALENTINE
WITH THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA SEASICK IS THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL BUT THE
URBAN COUNTIES ARE IN SUPPORT GO
AHEAD THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WELL AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE NICE TO
SEE YOU ALL IN PERSON FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A COUPLE OF YEARS-
AGAIN KIANA VALENTINE WITH URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF AB. NINETEEN THIRTY
TWO- SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE
AUTHORIZING LEGISLATION SB NINE
FOURTEEN COUNTIES HAVE YOU SEE
MARK OF FORTY FOR A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT PROJECTS. AND PLAN TO
CONTINUE TO USE IT INTO THE
FUTURE- ON A VARIETY OF
QUALIFYING PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
INCLUDING THE REMOVAL AND
RECONSTRUCTION OF BRIDGES. THE
IMPROVEMENTS AND RECONSTRUCTION
FOR FLOOD CONTROL CHANNELS AS
WELL AS LEVY PROTECTION
PROJECTS. ARE COUNTIES HAVE
FOUND THAT FOR MORE COMPLEX
PROJECT EARLY CONTRACTOR
INVOLVEMENT IS CRITICAL. AND
MOREOVER THE COST IMPACT FOR
PUBLIC WORKS AGENCIES TO PROCURE
INDIVIDUAL BOARD APPROVED
CONTRACTS CAN AMOUNT UP TO A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS APIECE.
SO THIS IS ALSO A COST SAVINGS
MEASURE IN ADDITION TO PROVIDING
COUNTIES THE ABILITY TO. SELECT
THE MOST APPROPRIATE DELIVERY
METHOD FOR A PARTICULAR PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECT. AND WITH THAT- WE
ARE IN SUPPORT AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY ONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN THIRTY
TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AT OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE FIFTEEN
. HI JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. BETTER NEXT
TIME IT COMES FROM LINE FOURTEEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
PRECIPITOUSLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES THE SPONSOR OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE ROOM FOR
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION ON AB.
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION AB
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE VERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THAT. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. SINGERMAN DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. OF A BONE MOVE THE
BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM LACKEY. OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RECOMMENDATION ON THE BILL AND
THANKS TO YOUR STAFF FOR THE
ASTUTE ANALYSIS OF THE BILL AND
I WILL APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE
WELL THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
ANOTHER ONE THAT'S A IMPORTANT
ALLOWED FLEXIBILITY FOR COUNTIES
TO USE CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT
RISK CONTRACTING I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
MOTIONS DO PASSED SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I IRAQI
ABOUT THE LOAN I WILL FOR RAMOS
THREE OF US HI THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS- NUMBER EIGHTY
VOEPEL RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT SIXTY
VOTE SIX ZERO WILK THE ROLLER
FOR OTHER THAT ARE IN MY A THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT NEXT IS AB
TWO ZERO EIGHT ONE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND WHEN YOU'RE READY DON'T RUSH
READ. READY GOOD AFTERNOON. WELL
THIS IS A AN EXTENSION OF A
PRIOR PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
CAME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE BILL
WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET TO
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
FURTHER ALLOW THE SERVICE OF
WHAT WATER NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
DISTRICTS AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS- THIS WOULD EXTEND
IT TO- I BELIEVE IT EXPIRES IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO GIVING THE
TRIBE IS A LITTLE MORE TIME TO
WORK ON THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
YES THANK YOU HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HAVE
ARE NOW TAKING TIME HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE BROWN A BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS. AS SOME OF YOU
MAY BE AWARE LIKE MANY TRIBES
LOCATED IN REMOTE AREAS WITH FEW
RESOURCES CORONA IS A WHOLLY
GROUNDWATER DEPENDENT TRIBAL
NATION. NOW BARONE IS ACTIVELY
SEEKING TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR
GROUNDWATER SUPPLIES AND WOULD
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE SUNSET
EXTENSION OF THE STATUTE THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA PASSED VIA
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW TO THE
HISTORICAL CONTEXT OF BARONE IS
A CURRENT LIMITED ACCESS TO
WATER. CORONA WAS FORCIBLY
REMOVED FROM THEIR ORIGINAL
RESERVATION ALONG THE BANKS OF
THE SAN DIEGO RIVER IN NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO SO THAT THE EL
CAPITAN RESERVOIR COULD BE
CONSTRUCTED FOR THE BENEFIT OF
URBAN SAN DIEGO. SINCE THEIR
MOVE TO THEIR SUBSTITUTE
RESERVATION CURRENT LOCATION
BROWN HAS ONLY HAD ACCESS TO
GROUNDWATERSUPPLIES WHILE THESE
SUPPLIES HAVE BEEN MAXIMIZED AND
SUSTAINABLE USE THROUGH
CONSERVATION AND WATER RECYCLING
EFFORTS- SUPPLEMENTAL WATER IS
CRITICAL TO BROWN IS FUTURE.
INTO THE TRAVEL RESIDENTS OF THE
RESERVATION WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MEASURE TO EXTEND THE SUNSET ON
AS PER LEGISLATION SO THAT
VERONA AND OTHER TRIBES IN
SIMILAR NEED. CAN AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF AN APPROPRIATE
OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN ACCESS TO
WATER IN A MANNER THAT IS HIGHLY
RESPECTFUL OF HISTORY AND TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY AND WE URGE OUR AYE
VOTE. KATIE HAVE ANY OTHER A
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. K. ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. A STEP UP
TO THE LIGHT. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ALX FELONIES ON
BEHALF OF THE OBAMA TELL PALMO
OF UPPER LAKE AND THE OF THE HAS
BANNED OF KAMALA INDIANS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
OKAY DO YOU HAVE ANY WHICH IS
WHAT I GUESS WITH ALL THE PHONE
LINES HAVE ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINES ARE LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT. OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
WE HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH LIKE FOR. LINE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
NICK BROKE UP SACRAMENTO
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THE AGUA
CALIENTE BAND OF CAHUILLA
INDIANS WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA'S EFFORTS
UNDER GENERALLY SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHTY ONES RECOGNITION
OF TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AND THE
IMPACT IT WILL HAVE THE SURFING
TRAVEL EFFORTS TO SUPPLEMENT
WATER SUPPLIES AND HOPE TO WORK
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOVING
FORWARD ABOUT TECHNICAL TWEAKS
TO ENSURE THE MAXIMUM AFFECTED.
IS REACHED THANKS SO MUCH. M.
LINE. TWENTY FIVE. HELLO THE
CORY LOCKWOOD AT THE BENDING
CYCLING BAND OF MONEY NATION AND
WE HAVE OUR SUPPORT. D. M. LINE
TWENTY SIX. YES FOLLOW TREAT ON
BEHALF OF THE KILLING THE BAND
OF THE SENIOR INDIANS IN FULL
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. OKAY DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS ANY OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. YOU HAVE ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
VOICE OPPOSITION. YOUR TURN
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION. COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE OF THEM
ZERO COMMENT AGAIN ONE SEVEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU THE BILL.
OKAY WE GOT A MOTION SECOND.
MOTION THE SECOND. ANYBODY FROM
COMMITTEE LIKE TO- EXCHANGE
QUESTIONS SIR. COMMENTS. YEAH WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND. I HAVE
SOMETHING FIRST OF ALL THAT-
NEEDS TO BE SEVEN ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE FIRST- THANK YOU- FOR
THOSE WHO CALLED IN SUPPORT I
WANTED JUST TO. NOTE THE-
COMMENTS BY THE A LOCAL IN THE
BAND OF CAHUILLA INDIANS WE WILL
BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM. AS
WE MOVE FORWARD IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO. ENSURE
THAT- ANY QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
THAT THEY MAY HAVE- ARE
INCORPORATED TO THE POLICY
MOVING FORWARD SO WITH THAT-
RESPECTFULLY OUTS FOR RIVAL.
VERY GOOD AND- ALONG THAT LINES
I NEED TO MAKE NOTE FOR THE
RECORD THAT THE- SYCUAN. BAND OF
THE KUMEYAAY NATION SUBMITTED A
REPORT LETTER FOR THIS BILL
WASN'T OVERTLY AMENDED FROM THE
ORIGINAL ANALYSIS FOR THE BILL.
BUT HAS BEEN CORRECTED. THANK
YOU SO WILL CALL FOR THE
QUESTION. AB ONE WHO HAS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FLOPPY HI PARDON
LOW ART ARBOR. HELLO THE FIVE
DIGITS ARE RESERVED HI AGREE
WITH THAT OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL.
WITH YOU CONGRATULATIONS THINGS
. WICKS SAN. WE OKAY LET'S GO
AHEAD AND- CONSIDER THE KIND WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND. FOR
THE CONSENT. EXACTLY OKAY WE ARE
MOTIONS SECOND I GUESS WE'LL
CALL FOR THE QUESTION. BLACKIE
HI. LOU HI WILL OFFER. RAMOS HI
THIS PAST LOVERS THAT'S FINE
NUMBER THREE DESIGN OKAY ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT RECORDS HAVE.
TIMES THAT'S GOOD NEWS WE GOT
ONE ONE BILL REMAINING ON THE
AUTHORS NOT PRESENT YET SO IF WE
COULD. CALL FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WORKS. THAT WOULD BE GREAT. WILL
STAND BY UNTIL THEY AUTHORIZE.
ISN'T THERE A DOLLAR A MINUTE
FINE. JUST IN TIME WE USE THAT
OF THE CORPORATE. JUST IN TIME
THANK. OKAY K. AB TWO TWO FOUR
FOUR YOU'RE ON THE FLOOR GOLF
BEFORE THANK YOUMISTER CHAIR-
AND FELLOW COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE- AND STAFF THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME HERE. I SAID THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THE ADAP SPACES ARE PRESERVED
AND NUMEROUS TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS AS WELL CALIFORNIA'S
RELIGIOUS COMMUNITIES ARE
CREATIVELY THINKING OF SOLUTIONS
TO ADDRESS THE STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS. RELIGIOUS COMMUNITIES
FROM THE BAY AREA SAN DIEGO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY IDENTIFIED UNDER
UTILIZED PROPERTIES AND
REDEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THROUGH ONE OF MY PREVIOUS BILLS
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE. HOWEVER
PLANS FOR PROPOSED RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS A NEW HOUSING HAVE
HIT ROADBLOCKS. DEVELOPERS
CANNOT UTILIZE AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
ONE BECAUSE THE LAW ONLY ALLOWS
FOR A PARKING REDUCTION FOR
EXISTING STRUCTURES. AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY FOUR BUILDS UPON AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE BY REDUCING
PARKING REQUIREMENTS FOR NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS AND ALLOWS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CRITICALLY NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS. THE
BILL SIMPLY MAKES EXISTING LAW
CONSISTENT FOR NEARLY PROPOSED
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. SOMEONE WHO WE ALL MAY
RECOGNIZE FROM HIS TIME IN MR
GABRIEL'S OFFICE ABRAM DHEAS
WITH THE NONPROFIT HOUSING OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE TIME
TESTIFIED TODAY I'M PLEASE
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO FORTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AT NPH REPRESENT AROUND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS ANDADVOCATES
WORKING TO SECURE RESOURCES AND
PROMOTE GOOD POLICY SUCH AS THIS
BILL. I KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF
WE APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
OUR AUTHOR AND SUPPORT OF
ENSURING THAT WE APPLY THESE
COMMONSENSE PARKING PRINCIPLES
EQUALLY SO THE NEW FAITH
COMMUNITIES CAN ALSO OPEN THE
DOORS TO CALIFORNIANS IN NEED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I'M HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS NEEDED.
RIGHT THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER- PEOPLE LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT LOOK LIKE IT
AT&T. WE'D LIKE TO REACH OUT TO
YOU NOW AND SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
COLORS OR WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. FOR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THE COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE HAVE A
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM WITH A LOT.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MORE MOMENT
WITH.
IN LINE TWENTY EIGHT THE BILL
HAS. YOUR TURN MEMBERS KILEY
SHELLEY CALLING ON BEHALF OF ALL
COME INTO COURT THANK YOU. ONE
MORE COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT.
AND LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL KNOWN HERE IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MINUTES
BURKE WERE CHAPTER AND I'M
PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE CAR A JEWISH SPIRITUAL
COMMUNITY IN LOS ANGELES. ARE
YOU COMMUNITY THAT WANT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE NEW BELL- WE
ARE BUILDING A GROUND ACNE
DEVELOPMENT A HOME FOR OUR OWN
INTERACTION UNITY. OF OVER A
THOUSAND FAMILIES HERE IN LA AND
WE HOPE TO BUILD FIFTY FIVE
UNITS OF PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR FORMERLY ON HOW
SENIOR CITIZENS ON OUR PROPERTY.
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW US TO HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY ABOUT THE USE OF OUR
LAND. AND ALLOW US TO PRIORITIZE
HOUSING OVER PARKING WHICH
ALIGNS WITH OUR CORE MISSION AND
VALUES AND THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE WE HOPE THAT THE COURT
ITSELF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU DO YOU
HAVE ANY WITNESSES OR WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. SEEING NONE. ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM THOUGH LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE WILL GO
BACK TO YOU AT AND T. YOU HAVE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION WE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
SEVEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT
AT THIS TIME WE CAME BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS. GET BACK TO YOU MA'AM. CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HEARING
ME OUT HERE- YOU KNOW I THINK
OUR RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS
REALLY WANNA BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION WE NEED TO MAKE IT IS
AS EASY AS POSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
DO SO RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND ALL THE CHAIRS NOT HERE BUT
SHE DOES SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND.
OVER SECOND. K. FIRST A SINGLE
CALL FOR THE QUESTION AB TWENTY
TWO FORTY FOUR TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. BLACKIE HI THAT THE
ALBUM WILL I BOERNER HORVATH.
RAMOS RAMOS I'D LOSE RIVAS HI
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I WILL TELL I WILL
TELL AYE AGUIAR-CURRY THE VOTE
IS CURRENTLY. SIX ZERO
REGULATIONS BRINGING FORWARD.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN WOULD WOULD NEED TO
CALL. FIRST SOME VOTES THAT WERE
MISSED. THANKS WITH A FIFTY
CALIBER. WHICH IS. AP TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR OR WIN AT S. B. TWO
OH SEVEN DOLLY. BOERNER HORVATH
WHILE MOST WELL MOST.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI I BRADBURY I
WILL CERTAINLY IS SEVEN. BOTH
SEVEN ZERO AND SECKAU UNDER.
YEAH THERE WAS A GOOD IDEA. AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE CALDERON THE
BILL FOR ME IS SIX ZERO. MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI RAMOS RAMOS I. EIGHT ZERO. BUT AB WAS IT.
THIRTY FIVE EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE
EIGHT ZERO. AB NINETY THIRTY TWO
DOLLARS EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. YEAH BERNHARDT DALY BURGER
HARDBACK ACT BERNHARDT AT FIVE
RAMOS RAMOS I SEE. BILLS OUT
EIGHT ZERO. AB TWENTY EIGHTY ONE
EDUARDO GARCIA. MOTION IS GOOD
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY HI THIRTY FIVE
BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH HI RAMOS RAMOS I
SEE BILLS NOT PAID ZERO. AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY FOUR WICKS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THE BOPARAN IS SIX
ZERO AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY ALL RIGHT
BOERNER HORVATH HI. HI BOTH OF
OUT EIGHT. I YEAH. RIGHT THE NEW
CONSENT HELLO. CALENDAR BERMAN I
BOERNER HORVATH I THE- CAN
SIGNAL RAMOS. YEAH YEAH YEAH IN
THE CAR RIGHT THIS IS A CONCERN
CAL OUT AIDS. EVERYTHING ELSE
WE'VE GOT IT ALL. THANK YOU ALL
AND THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. IN. YEAH. YEAH YEAH. CONVENTIONALLY.
OKAY. THAT'S. THE NEW. THE. THE
MISSION OF THE.
NEW ADDITIONS. FOR AND I HOPE.
PRINCIPLE HERE. THAT WOULD BE
GOOD ALL RIGHT. YEAH. PEOPLE
THANK YOU NICE. TO REALIZE. THE.